Built in 607AD in Nara, Japan
Horyu-ji Temple is the world's oldest
surviving wooden building.
Five storeys high,
it's still standing firm
despite being made from cypress trees
felled over 1,400 years ago.
And Horyu's great age
reveals a message for our future -
building with timber can be durable,
beautiful and practical
and it can even help
tackle climate change.
Here's why.
If we made 90% of our new buildings
from wood
rather than concrete and steel
we could reduce
our global carbon emissions by 4%.
That's more than the total
climate footprint of flying.
So why does building with wood
do such good?
First, trees absorb carbon dioxide
from the air as they grow.
This is naturally stored
in the beams and panels of buildings,
a process known as carbon capture.
So the timber in Horyu Temple
contains CO2 absorbed
from the planet's atmosphere
in the 7th Century.
Of course,
using wood means felling trees,
but so long as you're not chopping
down ancient forests,
you're maintaining the wildlife,
replanting,
and putting wood to long-term use,
it's sustainable.
In the last 15 years,
in the northern Hemisphere
total forest cover has increased
by an area of around 242,000 sq km,
about the size of the United Kingdom.
In fact, every seven seconds the
sustainable woodlands of Europe
yield enough timber to build
a four-person family home.
And it's not just Europe -
Canada can harvest enough trees every
year to house about a billion people.
An equally important carbon reduction
comes from what you're not using -
construction with natural materials
demands far less concrete and steel
and these are
massive climate culprits.
Steel-making accounts for around
8% of total global CO2 emissions
and cement accounts for a further 6%.
OK, not all of this
is going into buildings,
but they are a big customer.
It's the combination of stored carbon
and avoided emissions
that really tips the climate scales
for timber,
and a recent innovation has made wood
much more user-friendly.
CLT, or cross-laminated timber,
is made by layering conifer planks
at 90 degrees to each other
in three to seven tiers
and then gluing them together
producing a kind of chunky plywood.
These panels are suitable for walls,
floors, roofs, even lift shafts.
and their strength-to-weight ratio
is often better than concrete.
CLT can be used in schools,
offices and warehouses
and now there's a race to the sky
with 85m 'plyscrapers'
recently completed
in Austria and Norway.
So why are wooden buildings
still the exception?
Mainstream construction
is a risk-averse industry
and changing this
takes radical action.
One approach is law -
the French government has decreed
that at least 50% of every new public
building must be made of wood.
This not only allows those
structures to store more carbon
but also encourages
a generation of builders
to learn a timber-friendly skillset.
But how safe are wooden buildings,
you may ask?
Remembering the Great Fire
that gutted the medieval centre
of London in 1666?
In fact,
tests of CLT panels in a blaze
have shown they
tend to form a charcoal layer
that protects the core
and when combined with
heat-resistant glues and claddings
they can match or exceed the fire
resilience of conventional buildings.
There are other benefits too.
Studies suggest that wooden schools
can actually
lower the heart rate of pupils.
Even looking at a wooden wall
can reduce blood pressure.
So wood is not only renewable,
safe and climate-friendly,
it can also make you feel good.
Or to put it another way,
using wood is really good.